aspetta di benvenuti sanità stories oggi
il nuovo video speciale con il mio
cucciolo che venuti qua che carino sta
dormendo ma era una festa e fino a 30
secondi fa allora oggi faremo un video
speciale perché andremo a comprare tutto
quello che lui tocca al negozio di
animali quindi come funziona
praticamente siccome gli abbiamo
comprato un po di giochi però si è già
un po stancato e ci ruba le calze
rosicchiare scarpe eccetera eccetera
allora abbiamo deciso di comprare in
qualche giochino in più però invece di
sceglierlo noi e sceglierà lui ei suoi
giochini
quindi se gli era da solo i suoi giochi
andremo assieme a negozi di animali e
proviamo che si sveglia aveva però
perché così rossonera nulla che tra
negozi di animali e attiva subito lo
abbiamo già portato un paio di volte ed
è felicissimo quando l'inter negozi di
animali come comunque mentre 16
giocatori praticamente tratteremo al
negozio di animali li lasciamo scegliere
quello che vuole e di compreremo tutto
quello che volano alto lasciate un bel
live se volete vedere altri video o
challenge ovidio strani con berlino
berlino e kobudo ciao a tutti che volete
esatto quanti gliene sempre nei commenti
di altri video volete che facciamo con
berlino e ora mettetevi comodi prendete
patatine popcorner e andiamo subito
eccoci qua stiamo per arrivare ai
listini
[Musica]
robert il sistema sta rincorrendo gli
scontrini dai meloni vendiamo è contento
[Applauso]
richiamato marino
ecco qua tutti i giochi berlino si e
siamo un po cosa tocca berlino ma ci
sono tutti in ciò che qua mai visti
resta quindi fatta con una pallina primo
gioco scelto quant'altro 63 scegli cosa
per sé che cosa ho toccato allora
toccato questo quale quale questo blu ha
scocciato questo
[Musica]
aspetta aspetta che cos'è che cosa che
ha toccato ti amo papà è lungo gli piace
proprio in una copertina
prendiamo ancora al momento berlino ha
scelto tre articoli la copertina il
declino e la pallina con vieni berlino
dobbiamo essere qualcosa
benissimo
[Risate]
e quello far bene e di lingua berlino
dobbiamo fare quello
e così
se volete gemma mi piace proprio
e un coprisedile per la macchina devo
dire che ci serve veramente quindi va
benissimo
davvero
i rumori bene comune il cibo per camere
in corridoio che si dice infatti non mi
sembra vero di croccantini e traguardi
in area di szokol devo dire grazie
ne vuole qualcun altro
non che il paradiso dei crescenti
paradiso dei giochi come mai questa rosa
sapore collo berlino si è rilassato
infatti quando sta in braccio di rimasto
sempre sono la terra è di nuovo le
troppe a piloti
e vediamo quale sceglie marino quale
sceglie questo tutti e tre realtà come
questo questo quanto si aspetta aspetta
dopo la quando lino pallina questa forma
cosa europa quindi proprio questo e
cos'è questa pallina ma si mette
qualcuno dentro funziona allora mettiamo
al si sale e ridiamo falesie vediamo
quale se di marina quale se i quali
figli quale segni e certezza vs nime con
i segni di questo gioco quando via
[Risate]
ministro che mi piaccia più l'etichetta
che la pallina prendiamo questa questo
per tirare forse anche pare i denti
visto tutto poi sono i 20
adesso siamo lì piazze oppure cos'altro
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
stiamo scegliendo all'alimento festa per
caro abbiamo visto già controllando e
poi quale altro sentiremo perché qua lui
non si arriva
siamo un po
questo
eccoli qua
viviamo quale sceglie quale corre
berlino quale voi non quello voi quando
che gli interessi più le etichette
sbocco
[Musica]
[Risate]
ecco la loro mamma mia
siamo un cagnolino abilissimo a cuore
come possiamo portare a casa e nemmeno
ucciso nessuno
chiunque di noi
[Risate]
oggi a capo chino questo caso
[Musica]
è curioso ma anche paura
la fazione gatti non è perdente
bene
piazza
dove ci sono
dedico siamo tornati a casa ho speso un
bel po ma speriamo che questo renda
bilite berlino berlino detto tormento
non ci credo restando non abbiamo
neanche fatto in tempo a dirgli la
pettorina che si addormentano io volevo
fargli vedere tutti i giochini vedere
quali gli piace di più ma si sveglierà
ha dato raggiungerà questo potatore
anche cose fa per te allora video col
vediamo se non reagisce e si sveglia
allora innanzitutto merlino assetto
questo che è un comprensibile per
macchina che in realtà si serve proprio
per il viaggio in macchina e andiamo ad
aprirlo vediamo come si sa perché
berlino correggia tantissime zone
vediamo un po come questo compito di leo
alle travi disegnati che venendo grande
è sempre stato però è almeno almeno
aperto gli occhi e disegnate molto
morbido e dietro ci sono le cinghia sera
a carlo altalene lo utilizzeremo subito
questo
a provarlo la prima cosa no questa è una
delle cose che accettino berlino andiamo
a vedere le altre
vediamo se si sveglia con i giochini e
prossima cosa ha scelto questa copertina
lui ha già dei gusti di ma non aveva una
copertina no più che copertina è una
sorta di capitino
sarà contento era più carino quello che
fa bello e non certo a cuoricini celesti
è una sono fuori ci pensava palline da
capire allora apriamo lo vediamo un po
come una sorta di tappetino va bene
svegliato
questo ti piace e gli altri di piazza ma
non si faccia metto sempre interessato
alle figlie moretti che basta per terra
vedi un po siamo sicuri che versava ora
che lui e cuccioletto va bene ma se come
diventerà un gigante buono questo cane
con una città
vediamo se sei un morbido guardare
morbido attenzioni e rinnoviamo i primi
passi su questo nuovo tappeto diciamo la
pitturina cioè buono assaggiamo
[Musica]
tutto vero morbido che buono molto buono
allora andiamo a vedere gli altri giochi
con piazzamenti di mano chianti fi che
bello super morbidoso tra l'altro la
lasciano lo voglio io voglio dormire io
metterò lì così albero stalli mettevo
piegato su di lui non lo so perché ma
per giugno il suo bicchiere cose che non
sono giochi perché credo far rumore è un
po grazie per la tua boccuccia ha detto
che la tua pubblica e propri colline
aspetta togliamo l'etichetta che sanno
se la mangia e si apprezza apprezza il
cagnolone apprezza e più grosso di te
smetto di rosicchiare le mie scarpe ti
piaccia molto divertito
[Musica]
[Risate]
speriamo che non gli inizi a tutti
chiaro la notte bene sono contento che
gli piace anche perché l'ha scelto lui
poi vediamo cos'altro abbiamo preso
sognato di rho il tape corallina
questa è la prima cosa che si passava la
vediamo se lo insegue cosa facciamo
rimbalzare come se vi piace fatto vedere
poteva insegnarli a dare le cose a
lasciare perché andare dai preti la polo
[Risate]
e la bollina ora non lo mollerà piura
scappa con la pallina rino però aggiunto
divertendo ma poi ti piace la spagna
sono proprio contenta che assenza di
giochi adesso se la notizia è rotto
berlino si chiama l'inter ha più niente
di quel passato dopo gli otto nostro
dice la pallina chi preferisce la
barriera vediamo gli altri giochi che
abbiamo preso allora abbiamo preso
questo che ha scelto loro infatti a
sento lui che durerà poco sicuramente
perché non siano sgranocchiava tutto non
so se alleni che soltanto per le
superchicche sono cose un po più dure da
masticare vediamo berlino berlino niente
ormai acquistato con la palla servirà
merli
[Musica]
si si si sta giocando anzi di piazza di
pietra
ti piace ma magno tutto di fretta non si
mangia però è bene sono proprio contenta
che mi piace tutto quello che ha senso o
non è cosa da rosicchiare picchiando
buonasera immagine di carne abbandonato
la pallina lido sola felice lo
scoiattolino tutti e due ad ora la corda
testa che complessa però c'è anche
questo casino qua che dovrebbe insomma
possa aiutarlo perché sta tirando fuori
tutti i dentini quindi gli piace allo
stir e tutto troviamo l'etichetta anche
tanto
berlino 9 dic ha visto troppi giochi
bene tutto vuole proprio felicissima
come se fosse suo compleanno per me
mamma mia non sapone scendere guarda
[Musica]
e sa che davvero gli piace più di tutti
questi scogli a torino non l'avrei mai
detto che ero contento di vederlo così
felice allora c'è ancora un altro gioco
però vediamo se piacerà più dello
scoiattolo ma pallino questa pallina che
un po strana è un po strano che in
pratica una parte dietro di davanti di
plastica e poi sotto c'è un'altra
pallino c'è la pallina più morbida la
parte di fuori che è più dura questo
dice che galleggia quindi per giocarci
anche in acqua
violetta
[Musica]
ti piace mi piace si rivela stata
rosicchiato tutta i fianchi proprio è un
po grande per lui adesso che con questo
nome non ti preoccupare adesso la rompe
la faccia diventare più piccola la
faccia in mille pezzi
[Musica]
sì bella croccante sgranocchiava però
non chiamo tutto che stai facendo ti
stai ti stai divertendo con i nuovi
giocattoli no guarda questa che ciò
berlino allora proviamo a metterli tutti
i giochi in fila e vediamo
ma nel senso che ci proviamo ma non ci
riusciamo perché noi lui è troppo
intento a giocare sia detto queste cose
non le vorrà lasciare allora ecco berlin
aspetta aspetta stick abbiamo
posizionato la cover il tappetino la
pallina la corda l'altro
giochino lo scoiattolino e la cosa
vediamo quali svegliato prego scusi no
ma insomma ma lei già mollato ma il
papero si è chiusa il tappeto voglio
così tanti giochi brindisino richiardi
tappeto varley da no lo scoiattolino il
primo che ha preso e lo scoiattolino
quindi penso che lo spogliatoio sono un
po di essere un prezzo di taglia media
prendi la porta l'acqua berlino e
confuso non sa più quale prendere il
pallino e gli piace un sacco si già
seduto nel suo tappettino bene bene
davvero ti sei martello e se la portano
il suo tappetino bene già ha capito come
funziona il tappetino gli piace gli
piace e non manchino contempo che ve lo
vedeva che gli piacciono tutti giocatevi
meno male
e allora ecco qua berlino che preferisce
il tappeto a tutti gli altri giochi ma
insomma merlino dai primi video balzare
problematica già tutti quegli altri
lasciate un bel live se volete vedere
magari la seconda parte di questo video
in cui lo rifacciamo oppure
consigliateci che altre challenger altri
video volete vedere con berlino quindi
lasciate un bel like fateci sapere che
altri video volete vedere e ora cliccate
su né di queste quattro cartellini e per
vedere i prossimi video e cade su quello
che preferite e buona visione
ciao ciao anche da berlino che impegnato
a rosicchiarsi tutti i giocattoli